>>FLORIDA GOVERNOR RICK SCOTT
IS AMONG A GROWING CHORUS OF
THOSE CALLING FOR FBI DIRECTOR
CHRISTOPHER WRAY TO RESIGN.
WE LEARNED TODAY THAT A CALLER
TIPPED THE BUREAU OFF JUST LAST
MONTH ABOUT THE FLORIDA SHOOTING
SUSPECT NIKOLAS CRUZ.
THEY WERE TOLD HE WANTED TO KILL
PEOPLE AND WAS A POTENTIAL
SCHOOL SHOOTER.
HOW COULD THE FBI BOTCH THIS SO
BADLY?
JOINING US NOW IS STEVE ROGERS,
A FORMER MEMBER OF THE FBI JOINT
TERRORIST TASK FORCE.
THIS IS JUST A HEARTBREAKER IN
SO MANY WAYS.
I TRY TO PUT MYSELF IN THE
POSITION OF A PARENT OR SPOUSE.
THE FBI GETS THIS YOUTUBE TIP IN
SEPTEMBER AND FOR SOME REASON
COULDN’T FIGURE OUT WHO POSTED
THAT COMMENT.
AND THEN IN JANUARY, A TIPSTER
CALLS IN AND IT’S VERY SPECIFIC.
A PERSON CLOSE TO CRUZ, HE HAS A
GUN, ET CETERA, ET CETERA, HE
COULD SHOOT THE SCHOOL.
AND THEN NOTHING.
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> LAURA, THIS WAS AN EPIC
FAILURE AT LEADERSHIP
HEADQUARTERS.
AN EPIC FAILURE OF INFORMATION
SHARING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN THE EARLY
DAYS OF HIS CAMPAIGN WONDERS
ABOUT PROBLEMS IN OUR
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES.
THE PRESIDENT WAS RIGHT.
I’VE GOT TO TELL YOU, THE
MAGNITUDE, THE MOST PROFOUND TIP
THEY GOT WAS WHAT WAS ON THAT
YOUTUBE ABOUT BEING A
PROFESSIONAL SHOOTER.
YOU CONNECT THE DOTS.
YOU DON’T STOP THE
INVESTIGATION.
WHEN I HEARD THE FBI AGENT TALK
ABOUT, WELL, WE LOOKED AT THE
YOUTUBE AND COULDN’T FIND THE IP
ADDRESS.
I WAS STUNNED.
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU DO?
IT WOULD BE SIMPLE.
WHY NOT JUST PUT THE GUY’S NAME
IN THE INSTAGRAM OR FACEBOOK
PLATFORM?
IT WAS HIS NAME. AND LOOKED WHAT
CAME UP.
THEY WOULD HAVE HAD THE NAME AND
GOTTEN THE LOCAL POLICE.
THE QUESTION I HAD AND I BELIEVE
STILL HAS TO BE LOOKED INTO, DID
THE LOCAL POLICE GIVE THE FBI
ANY INFORMATION AT ALL REGARDING
THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CALLS?
BUT WHEN THAT NAME CAME UP, I’M
WONDERING ALL THE INFORMATION
THE POLICE HAD ABOUT THIS GUY,
AND ON THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CALLS, WE ASKED THE QUESTION,
ARE THERE ANY WEAPONS IN THE
HOUSE?
USUALLY EVERY POLICE DEPARTMENT
HAS A DATABASE OF EVERY HOME
THAT HAS A WEAPON TO PROTECT
OFFICERS.
THERE WAS LITTLE OR NO
INFORMATION SHARING AND THAT’S
WHAT HAS TO BE INVESTIGATED.
>> THEY HAD BEEN TO HIS HOUSE
39 TIMES FOR A VARIETY OF
THINGS.
HIS MOTHER WAS AFRAID OF HIM.
HE WAS CUTTING HIMSELF ON
INSTAGRAM AFTER HIS GIRLFRIEND
BROKE UP WITH HIM.
HE WAS A DECENT EMPLOYEE AT THE
DOLLAR GENERAL STORE, BUT OTHER
THAN THAT HE WAS A TOTAL NUT
JOB.
IT WAS RED FLAG AFTER RED FLAG.
BUT IT’S ALMOST PEOPLE ARE
WORRIED ABOUT OFFENDING SOMEONE
AND BRIDGING SOMEONE’S PRIVACY.
I DON’T KNOW IF THEY’RE JUST
OVERLOADED OR BUREAUCRACY.
I THINK IT WAS A COLOSSAL
MISTAKE ON THE LOCAL, STATE, AND
FEDERAL LEVEL.
BUT THE FEDERAL LEVEL TAKES THE
CAKE FOR ME.
>> THERE’S NO EXCUSE FOR WHAT
HAPPENED THERE.
LOOK, COPS GET INSTINCT.
AND I’VE ASKED ALL WEEK, ANY FBI
AGENT WHO KNOWS ANYTHING ABOUT
HOW THIS HAPPENED AND WHERE THE
FAILURES WERE, LAURA, THEY NEED
TO COME FORWARD.
COPS PUT UP THIS BLUE WALL OF
SILENCE.
AND IT HAPPENS ON A LOCAL AND
FEDERAL LEVEL.
TEAR DOWN THAT BLUE WALL OF
SILENCE FOR THE GOOD OF THIS
COUNTRY.
A LOT OF COPS KNOW A LOT OF
THINGS AND THEY WEREN’T COME
FORWARD FOR ONE REASON OR
ANOTHER.
BUT IN THIS CASE THEY’VE GOT TO
COME FORWARD.
>> AND IT’S ALSO AMAZING IN
THAT YOUTUBE VISIT THAT THE FBI
FIELD OFFICE IN MISSISSIPPI MADE
TO THE MAN WHO RAISED AN ALARM
ABOUT IT.
THEY VISITED HIM TWICE.
THEY HAD THE NAME NIKOLAS CRUZ
FROM THE POSTING.
WHY WASN’T THAT PART OF THE FBI
FILE SYSTEM SO WHEN THE CALL
CAME IN, IT SEEMED LIKE THERE
SHOULD BE A CROSS-REFERENCING
PROGRAM.
MAYBE IT’S SILLY WHAT I’M
SAYING.
>> IT’S NOT SILLY.
DID LOCAL POLICE, DID THE SCHOOL
SYSTEM SHARE INFORMATION?
AND WHEN THIS PARTICULAR NAME
CAME UP -- I’M SURE THE LOCAL
POLICE SAW THAT YOUTUBE.
EVERYBODY SEEMED TO HAVE KNOWN
ABOUT IT.
WHEN THAT NAME CAME UP, DID
ANYBODY THINK, MAYBE WE SHOULD
CHECK WITH FEDERAL AUTHORITIES
OR MAYBE FEDERAL AUTHORITIES
SHOULD CHECK WITH THE LOCALS IF
THEY FOUND OUT WHERE THIS WAS.
>> SHOULD THE FBI DIRECTOR
RESIGN?
>> I SAID IT EARLIER AND I’LL
SAY IT AGAIN THAT THE ENTIRE
LEADERSHIP SHOULD RESIGN OR BE
FIRED.
I’M GLAD HE NOW HAS ATTORNEY
GENERAL SESSIONS LOOKING INTO IT
AND INVESTIGATING IT.